gauthier et finalement au coeur de ces
tensions entre la russie et les
occidentaux les ukrainiens notamment
de la russie accusé l'otan de vouloir
s'étendre et y compris à l'ukraine mais
aussi parce que on a entendu le
secrétaire de l'otan viennent
stoltenberg qui c'est un exercice
impossible pour lui c'est un exercice de
grand écart parce que vous avez entendu
vous avez vu qu'il a détaillé par le
menu
l'historique de cette crise est à dire
depuis 2014 que le détail il est entré
dans les détails non seulement de
mobilisation russes mais aussi de
violations du droit international par la
russie bref il fournit toutes les
arguments tous les toutes les précisions
toutes les qualités toutes les quantités
pour justifier normalement ce qui
devrait être une intervention ou moins
un soutien militaire de l'otan or quand
on en arrive à ce chapitre là de sa
démonstration il n'y a rien il n'y a pas
de défense militaire de l'otan alors il
ya ce qu'il a dit c'est à dire un
renforcement de la présence des troupes
de l'otan dans les régions qui sont en
fait en bordure de celle qui est qui est
concerné directement par le conflit mais
il a ajouté qu' il ne s'agissait pas
d'un déploiement ou d'une préparation
des soldats de l'otan mais plus d'un
renforcement donc on est là dans la
limite absolue ce qui veut dire
concrètement que pour vladimir poutine
c'est presque un blanc seing pour
pouvoir continuer c'est à dire qu'il a
l'assurance qu'il n'y aura pas de
réplique militaire de la part de l'otan
ce qui veut dire que les ukrainiens
seront seuls en cas d'invasion alors
c'est ce que c'est ce que le président
volodine zen ce qu'il y avait 10
en nous soutenant pas militairement vous
permettait une invasion de la russie et
effectivement cette invasion quelle
qu'elle soit c'est à dire limiter au
donbass comme ça l'est pour l'instant où
étendu à l'ensemble de l'ukraine ou
étendu à ceux qu'on appelle les oblasts
de du dôme bas c'est à dire l'ensemble
des régions parce que pour l'instant les
séparatistes occupe une moitié on va
dire même un peu moins moitié delà de la
région totale du donbass donc là ça
pourrait être une extension de cette
session et qui serait bien évidemment
soutenu et appuyé militairement par
moscou donc là on est dans la limite
bien sûr de l'exercice de l'otan qui est
effectivement une façon de dire nous
sommes nous soutenons l'ukraine
l'ukraine est un partenaire pour nous
mais au fond ne soutiendra pas
militairement il y a une seule
possibilité elle les minimes c'est ce
que le président ukrainien avait
réclamée c'est un armement de l'armée
ukrainienne qui depuis un certain nombre
d'années
a été quand même relevé dans ce domaine
là mais qui n'est pas non plus de taille
à faire désolé gauthier mai